hey steph yes what's up dre
it's a nice shirt you got on i want to
know uh how many zebras had to die for
you to look fly
[Laughter]
oh no
what was that wait where did charles go
what'd you do with him
her drum let him know
that is so good
way to go charles
got it curry and manning
strike first
stephen curry this is fourth
yeah well you want to just give that to
him
that's good we'll give you that one oh
my goodness that's disrespectful right
that's a strong cocky move right right i
don't let it backfire
we're going to run out of daylight hey
it's off season
i'm tired of your colleagues
disrespecting you i had balls made
with shaq's face on it oh yeah knock a
shack ball in the hole
this is okay that's the ugliest ball in
the world right here
curry hundred thousand on staff curry
thank you vegas
nope dude
yeah very nice touch well go in
this is really good here from charles
charles barkley ladies and gentlemen
all right yes go all right you're good
you guys got it all right let's go
concede give the hole to manning
and curry my bad all right
oh boy look out charles is in a
prickly pear cactus blast it out
uh-oh nope just a message to everybody
don't hit it in the desert
only two balls in the desert don't feel
like you can be superman
and a 200-yard hook or hit it over some
roots a lot of lessons we're learning
today that's good what not to do a lot
of freaking lessons we're learning today
capital one's a match peyton manning
with the driver
he's been hitting it well lost that one
a little right
where's that
oh not good i think we're all a little
boy
all right partner
now barkley that might be all right
yikes he is propping him up all right
this is a huge one here
for birdie they'll get two shots out
by peyton manning okay
win capital ones the match champions
outstanding phil mickelson and charles
barkley congratulations
good work brother two people all right
two people thought this was gonna happen
you and me and that's it